I managed coil I'm a product manager for
Chrome browser enterprise and here's the
agenda today we're gonna talk about why
the browser is becoming increasingly
important in the enterprise we're gonna
talk about Chrome browser benefits
improvements since last year future
enhancements that are coming in 2019 and
finally how to get started managing
Chrome browser Enterprise so let's get
started we all know the way that
enterprises work is changing this is
being driven by rapid technology changes
what was once impossible is now possible
and what was once possible is now normal
employees want flexibility agility speed
and access to what they want when they
want it people want to be able to pick
up their kids take calls from the car
work from home and respond to email
wherever they are we all know this and
experience this every day with the
affordability of cloud computing the
reach of mobile devices and the ubiquity
of fast connectivity technology in the
work environment is vastly different
from what it used to be so let's look at
some stats 84% of people work in virtual
environments at least part of the time
on average employee has 22 apps and they
have three devices almost half of those
devices store some business critical
data and finally remote work is the norm
for about 70% of your traditional
information workers so what you need is
a secure browser that can be managed
centrally while keeping employees
productive big drumroll that's Chrome
browser enterprise it provides secure
trusted access
to data apps and cloud services the
browser also connects employees on any
device and proactively protects users
while they work your users get a
consistent customizable experience
wherever they want to work and IT admins
can easily manage permissions and
policies across every user every device
and every platform that they have in
their enterprise it should be no
surprise to learn that Chrome browser
has been evolving over the past ten
years to support enterprise users we
started with administrative GPOs and
then we added features additional
features that customers requested for
enterprise use cases as the web has
grown so have our enterprise
capabilities also in the past year we've
added the ability to manage Chrome
browser from Google's admin console and
we'll detail
additional feature enhancements later in
the presentation
first let's talk about the impact that
chrome can have on an average enterprise
of about 20,000 employees Forrester
consulting has said 1 Chrome is easier
to troubleshoot and 2 helped us
turnaround times are much much faster
so overall end-user productivity
increases and enterprises see tangible
benefits within six months this further
validates that Chrome browser can enable
your IT admins IT Help Desk and
employees to be more productive so quick
pull of the audience how many of you are
Chrome browser enterprise users hands
higher come on come on
thank you I appreciate it all right
let's talk about what we've done since
last year first we've improved security
in many many different ways the web is a
dangerous place and we have blocked
third-party processes from hijacking
Chrome
- we've improved the verification
process for extensions and we've
prevented deceptive extensions from
being installed in the enterprise 3
we've let Enterprise users know if their
enterprise password has been compromised
and if it's being used outside of their
company and last we've rolled out site
isolation to contain threats this is a
key differentiator of Chrome browser to
keep your end-users safe but-but-but-but
no security discussion would be complete
without discussing flash for the past 20
years yeah you can laugh for the past 20
years flash has helped shape the way
that you play games browse the web watch
videos and run applications but over the
last few years
flash has actually become less common
three years ago
80 percent of flash users excuse me
eighty percent of Chrome users visited a
flash web site once a day
now flash usage is only six percent and
it continues to decline this trend shows
that websites are moving to open web
technologies such as html5 and pwace
which are faster and more efficient than
flash so IT admins hopefully I'm looking
at all of you please work with your
software vendors to find a migration
path away from flash since next 2013
we've also streamlined how a browser is
managed in existing environments for
example we know a lot of you use
third-party tools such as SCCM and
Intune to manage your applications we
verified that Chrome browser GPIOs can
be configured properly from these tools
and improved our documentation to help
admins configure chrome within these
tools we've tested that browser sign-in
and restrict sign-in pattern policies
work together to ensure that your users
can
sign into Chrome browser with the
correct work email third many customers
want statistics on how their users use
Chrome browser we've built a purely
optional extension that an administrator
can install on a Chrome browser they can
monitor the resource consumption of
Chrome browser by memory they can see
they're signed in status they can see
the connectivity of the device and many
many other machine information
excuse me machine configuration policies
the extension data is stored locally in
JSON on that device so you can use
Splunk or SCCM to read that information
and build your own reports fourth we've
added relaunched notifications these
policies allow you to influence how
often your user gets reminded that a new
version of chrome is available to
download and many of our customers had
said that this helps quite a bit with
keeping their users on the most current
version of chrome this is another
feature that we've added recently called
manage five and it was built with a lot
of feedback from your employees it helps
increase the transparency between admins
and end-users we're letting employees
easily see the administrative policies
that are being set up in their
environment so that they know their
browser is being managed we definitely
expect some discussion around this
feature so we will continue to iterate
on it over the next few months with your
feedback now let's move on to what's
happening in 2019 this is our
forward-looking roadmap we have a lot of
great features coming and I'm gonna I'm
going to discuss each one of these in
more detail
so first Chrome browser cloud management
has just launched this will enable
admins to easily manage chrome
deployments of any size from the cloud
admins can enroll devices into
organizational units and manage all the
desktop Chrome browsers of these
enrolled devices through Google admin
console they can also apply policies to
organizational units and deploy those
policies to all the browser's that are
enrolled admins will be able to gain
insights into their deployment and they
will be able to delegate admin
responsibilities so if you have a large
organization you could delegate an admin
for finance and admin for HR and admin
for sales and admin for any other group
that you might have in your organization
note that administrators do
administrators need to have a Google
account but your end-users do not what
we do is that we enroll the browser via
a token which admins can runes can
retrieve from the Google admin console
there's a lot of great features in this
product and I won't be able to cover
them all in this session please check
out the session later today with my
colleague Phil and Starbucks to learn
how they have deployed Chrome browser
cloud management at their company next
feature legacy browser support this is a
feature that we've actually had for a
couple years that allows admins to have
chrome as the default browser for the
majority of their websites but it will
allow them to automatically fall back to
a legacy browser for some minority set
of legacy websites in addition users are
endlessly switched back to Chrome from
that legacy browser when they try to
access a modern web site so it's really
really useful while this feature has
been available for many years it's now
going to be much easier to deploy
because it's being built into Chrome and
you won't have to rely on an additional
extension we've actually heard a lot of
great feedback from this
feature from early adopters of the
integrated lbs and we really hope to
hear from you and hope that you enjoy it
as well we will also be adding controls
for legacy browser support into the
admin console later this year another
feature that is getting rolled out is
part of a suite of features called
update controls many of our customers
have requested the ability to pin Chrome
to specific versions we launched this
feature and it's really meant for
companies excuse me we've already
launched this feature and we've gotten
feedback from companies and they've told
us this is super helpful when they have
strict management change management
requirements and/or compliance needs
what we are now doing is offering a way
for customers to roll back a new version
of Chrome to an old version of Chrome
and this is meant as a temporary measure
or emergency workaround we always
recommend to stay on the newest version
of Chrome so that you're up to date with
the latest security patches today these
features are available as GPO only and
we will add these controls to the admin
console later this year next how many of
you use passwords I use passwords I have
a corporate password
sometimes I accidently use that password
outside of my company so we've built a
feature called password alert this will
alert your employees when they use their
corporate password on a non whitelisted
website and what the feature does it
will actually instruct them to reset
their password this prevents corporate
passwords from being fished by malicious
third party websites we also plan to
enable password alert from the admin
console so that IT admins can get
reports on who is reusing their password
outside of their company this helps
quite a bit for compliance
next
Chrome browser has a ton of policies we
know that we've had to make improvements
towards documenting these policies and
we're going to update our policy page
right now when you go to our policy list
it's a huge like just gigantic webpage
of 300 plus policies that span Chrome
browser and chrome OS you've asked for
an easier way to search through these
policies and that's what we're doing
you're going to be able to filter by
operating system you're going to be able
to filter by browser version and your
gold you're going to be able to filter
by a couple other things to more easily
allow you to see when a new policy was
added onto omnibox omnibox is one of my
most favorite features and we continue
to look at omnibox as a key entry point
for surfacing search results now G suite
admins have the option to allow chrome
omnibox to show document suggestions
from Google Drive when a user does a
search and this is all enabled from
within your company firewall not
external note that there are three
things that an admin must do to enable
this feature one you have to have a G
suite account and you have to turn on
this setting two users have to be signed
in to Chrome that should be obvious and
three users have to have cloud sync
turned on we use this feature every day
at Google and I can tell you it's super
useful for finding that document that
you just can't remember another UX
related feature is tab groups which is
super amazing tab groups will increase
the productivity for users that want
better tools to manage their workflows
especially their business workflows
you'll be able to group related tabs
together so that it's easier to find
your work stream and stay focused
and those are some of our major features
that are coming in 2019 just as a
reminder we have an extensive list of
resources for our customers that don't
buy support we have release notes Help
Center articles and a free enterprise
forum and if you're interested in
purchasing support please contact our
Chrome Enterprise Browser specialists at
google.com and they'll tell you what's
included in the Support Package noriko
is right back there she's smiling go say
hi to her after the session all right
we're almost done but we have many other
sessions today tomorrow and Thursday and
these will all go into more depth about
Chrome browser Enterprise so if you're
trying to pitch Chrome inside of your
company I highly recommend checking out
the session with Blue Cross Blue Shield
and their journey to make Chrome the
primary browser in their enterprise
[Music]
you